you know the questions when it comes to
marketing and life in general is always
like kind of like health and fitness
like there's everyone here knows how to
be in better shape eat better work out
you know and everyone in this room knows
you could have made one [__] Tick
Tock video that went viral and would
have sold that [__] out but you didn't
do it the question becomes why are you
concerned if you posted on Tick Tock
that only got nine views do you have the
humility to actually build a business
are you worried about people looking at
your videos and seeing if they only got
six views and laughing like what's in it
in your head that's stopping you from
the thing you know that you should be
doing okay
anything I can answer even outside of
the BM stuff if in case someone here has
consumed it or anything I can bring some
value what's your name
Daniel nice to meet you bro oh I just
kind of got a question about kind of
inspiration yep sometimes kind of
when you're in this kind of like path
alone I'm kind of like blue strike if
you're on the right path or not and even
though like people are telling you that
you are kind of like for yourself like
you're telling yourself that you might
not mean that bad so I'm kind of just
like asking the question is like how do
you keep getting inspired how do you
keep pushing yourself how do you see
well I think I think the question you're
asking might be a little bit more
complex which is
what you don't want to do is is create
motivation to do something you don't
want to do notice how you said other
people said you're on the right path
like do you think you're on the right
path are you interested in actually
doing it the biggest issue for all you
at this point in your life cycle is are
you doing this for yourself or are you
doing this for someone else right like
why are you doing this when I was your
age entrepreneurship wasn't even a thing
now it's a thing I'm 47 years old and
young people might think it's cool I'm
in the room right now that's [__]
crazy to me
that wasn't real when I was 20. right
like entrepreneurs look like nerds and
like and you know like it just wasn't a
thing now it's cool so the thing I'm
always worried about with Babson I spoke
to USC this week the entrepreneur class
now that it's a thing
it's more like being an athlete or like
a rapper like it's like cool so I'm like
who's in here doing this only because
they think it's cool it's not really who
they are they're really a guidance
counselor they're really a ski
instructor they're really a cook they're
really you know like they they're really
just a top 15 executive the 15th biggest
executive at Facebook made 80 trillion
dollars
you know what I mean not that exact
number but like a lot
so a the first when I hear that question
from you I'm like
it's really easy to be motivated when
you're doing what the [__] you're
supposed to be doing in your soul
not in the thing that gets you to the
next place like I'm gonna get a job
after school or I'll I'm gonna make 100K
when I'm 25 or I'm gonna make a million
like so you know
that's different than another thing that
might be coming up for some of the
people in the room which is patience
so many people here are so worried about
what people think about them they're
trying to rush to the win
so it's sometimes hard to stay motivated
when you're impatient
because because your practical brain's
like you're not going to really be at
that level of like what entrepreneurship
can do for you until 28 32. when you're
in this room 32 seems like a million I
remember
I remember being under 22 and thinking
32 is like a lot like my cousin was 30.
Bobby was 30 when I started working at
my dad's liquor store I thought he was
old as [__]
it was yeah he was like that was like a
grown ass man
right so I come in here at 47 I'm 17
years older than Bobby was when I was
looking at him at your age and I'm
telling you I feel like I'm in this
class with y'all
like it still feels that fresh and young
in here
so you got time
but sometimes it's hard because you're
not patient and you're not patient
because you're worried about what other
people think
of course okay here's your hands
all right so I want to start a marketing
agency and I was wondering would you
recommend joining a teenager to learn
they're just getting that's a funny
question it's really funny I just the
other day said I [__] up and should
have made AJ who went to BU not too far
from you guys I wish he went to another
Agency for a year before we started
Vayner because we just learned
everything in the [__] streets and
like did so much [__] wrong for so long
that if he was there for a year he would
have siphoned all that out and we would
have been good so you know ironically
you know five years ago I might have
said to you just don't worry about the
dumb [__] we do and everybody else does
with clear fresh eyes you might do
something more interesting I think
there's a balance like a year you can
only get so many bad habits and you
probably will learn a lot of like basic
[__] and especially if you're capable of
being at a school like this your brain
works in a manner where you can learn
that [__] and so you know I would say
both work
it completely comes down to you I was
incapable of working somewhere else it
was never in my DNA but that's why I was
also incapable of going to Babson
because I wasn't able to conform to even
School in junior high in high school for
all of you you have that temperament
otherwise you wouldn't be here so you
might want to use that to your advantage
I don't say that as a pride I don't say
that I couldn't work I wish I could have
might have sped up some [__] for me I
wish I wasn't so 100 80 would have been
beautiful and so you got to be
self-aware of who you are how would you
learn better are you like me and you
learn it in the dirt and it's just like
you need that creative process or are
you like a lot of other people where the
context of like seeing it in motion will
allow you I I really wish I told AJ to
go work at an agency for a year would
have helped us a lot
right here yes sir oh my name is Dan
brand yep I just launched it a couple
months ago congrats it's a great product
but you know right now I'm kind of
struggling to get sales so I'm curious
what you would are you selling it on
Shopify or Amazon oh Shopify it just
went on Amazon today actually amazing so
when you sell [__] you have to create
demand
so what are you doing to Great demand
right now I I first tried to advertise
me on Facebook but the problem that is I
don't think the budget right now to be
doing paid media in that way how much
organic creative did you do honestly not
yeah
you know the questions when it comes to
marketing and life in general is always
like kind of like health and fitness
like there's everyone here knows how to
be in better shape eat better work out
but now go do it even like the way we
just had that exchange you didn't even
allow me to get to the part you already
knew like yeah like if like you know and
everyone in this room knows you could
have made one [__] Tick Tock video
that went viral and would have sold that
[__] out
but you didn't do it the question
becomes why like these are the things
that I'm most fascinated by there's
nobody 20 [__] years old that doesn't
realize they should be posting 40 times
a day organically on YouTube shorts tick
tock you know you may not know Facebook
reels is popping off because you're too
young and you're not in a marketing
company like this that's spending a lot
of time but you definitely know you
should be posting on [__] Tick Tock
are you concerned if you posted on Tick
Tock that it only got nine views do you
have the humility to actually build a
business are you worried about people
looking at your videos and seeing if
they only got six views and laughing
like what's in it in your head that's
stopping you from the thing you know
that you should be doing
you could DM 100 people and say you want
to send samples to them
like
there was 15 20 people what's happening
okay someone posted it like like I saw a
notification
nice man it's the grind right it's like
build build build but your own organic
content is the best because it's free
you have to ship that [__] it cost you
to make it right like they may not post
it that costs money you trying to make
creative organically on social
costs time but [__] free
when I saw this book and like the
conversations I had with a lot of like
my teachers and my parents about like
burning the boats and toss plan to be
away and I was wondering what you think
about like like for example like my dad
always tells me all the time to save a
bunch of my money and not like put take
a lot of risks at as in like buying a
bunch of inventory hoping to sell it you
know
and I have another FME teacher
one of our classes that always tells me
you know take the risk see if it works
see if it doesn't this is the thing that
is [__] the world I'll use politics
everyone's so [__] red and so blue
when the answer is purple
everyone's pulling so hard from like
pops is saying like save every [__]
dog because it worked for pops and
teachers saying take the high risk
because he's seen example or she's seen
examples of high risk the answer is
nobody knows I should have taken risks
because I was good at it if you're bad
at it and you take risks You're Gonna
Lose you're going to wake up in debt
with a warehouse full of [__] nobody
really knows and so I think you find the
medium which is like take micro risk you
understand too many people are so
ideological like I'm taking risks I'm
burning the [__] boat and you take
all eighteen hundred dollars you got to
your [__] name and you buy [__]
inventory and try to go with no idea
what the [__] gonna happen versus
spend five hundred dollars and go like
why like everyone's just gotten too
extreme
right but look I will say this
as like a thing that I can leave you
with that really [__] resonates for
me
this is this next eight to ten years is
when you should take the biggest risks
of your life
on some real [__] it gets harder to take
risks when you're old we're not old but
like oh for you we're old you know what
I mean like this is when four of you can
live in the same shitty [__]
apartment eating shitty food not like
this is when you can the problem is too
many people either rush into being grown
up because their parents are telling
them or would rather take 70 000 on a
job so they can buy some dumb [__] like
some dunks and a [__] decent car
versus chasing their dream this is when
you need to take the biggest risks of
your life because when you're 40 it gets
harder when you have family when you
have responsibilities this is the by far
the best time people got it reversed
when you get out of school that's when
you should go craziest but you have to
live humble and that's the part that
everyone struggles with people literally
sacrifice their dreams to be able to buy
expensive cocktails and go to like
Coachella you understand so like hey
find the middle in those two pieces of
ice but in the macro
you never can live on no money more than
23.
because you're willing to team up with
each other just gotta be a little more
strategic too many kids talk big game
that they're gonna [__] do something
but then take jobs just so they could
spend it on Uber and [__] Starbucks
take the [__] bus and [__] make
your own coffee
you understand all of a sudden
miraculously got money to take a risk
my little brother has autism and growing
up he'd always like lose his fidget toys
yeah so after looking at some of your
content and getting inspired to do
something entrepreneurial I created this
thing called fidget infused clothing so
we attached fitted toys love right to
help people with Autism or ADHD not lose
it and three years later now 19 I've
been on People magazine ABC Inside
Edition the Boston Globe and we've
helped over 2 000 families so that's
what's up bro do me a favor don't give
up on this thing for a real minute and
right now it's easy but when you're 27
and you have fourteen thousand dollars
to your name and you're still going at
it and you've been doing it for five six
seven years it gets harder but this is
such a [__] like you'll never be more
passionate about anything it's
impossible it hits too close to your
heart you'll never have the juice to do
anything no matter what you do in your
life it will never matter more to you
than this brand so back to what we were
just talking about this is where you got
to put your head down and go to sleep
for a decade
don't even think about anything else but
just trying to build this for 10 years
and and then if it's not there then
you'd be like okay because at 90 if you
bounce on this after three years and
want to get to the next thing you'll
regret it because it's too important to
you yeah
pleasure my man I gotta run I apologize
thank you have the best day take care
everyone
foreign